the thing that y'all are not understanding is that being a fat person
is legitimately traumatizing
not like internet oh
this is traumatizing
traumatizing as in I this year was diagnosed with cptsd
complex Post traumatic stress disorder
as a result of growing up as a fat person and the trauma that comes with that
there is legitimate trauma that comes with growing up as a child
and believing that your entire value is tied into your body
that no one will love you because you're fat and that you will not have any love
any success any friends because you are fat
society literally treats fat people as if we are worthless
like like
I don't know how y'all think that that shit is not gonna fuck people up
like it just
it does it messes with your head
like I
it's crazy because the amount of hate that I receive for being a fat person
like if you guys saw like
the shit people said to me on the internet
you would be flabbergasted
like this is not just like
a quirky oh
you know like
it's really hard being fat
no it's like in your developmental stages
you are constantly thinking about your body and like
feeling absolutely worthless to the point where like
you feel dehumanized
I don't know that shit
it just it messes you up
you know and like
I'm dealing with it like it's
I'm fine it's not like
you know I think that experience is very different for everybody else
and I think obviously this like
this definitely varies person to person
but like I don't think that y'all like
can fully grasp the legitimate like
trauma that comes with being a fat person
in the world like
I just I don't think that y'all fully get it
nobody is meant to deal with that like
level of consistent criticism and hatred
it's not like
oh like
woe is me my life is so hard
like sob story
it's just like I
I'm not saying this like
to ask for sympathy by any means
I'm just saying this because like
I just genuinely don't think people understand the mental toll that it takes
and it's really funny because if you're
you're gonna say
I care about fat people's health
like the only reason I'm commenting on their body
is because I care about their health
like that's not true
you don't you're a virtue signaling
and you're using this idea of health to give you a reason to
be cruel to fat people
that's just that's literally what it is
what if you actually cared about fat people's health
like mental health is also a factor in that
and a lot of time
let's say a fat person can't take care of themselves
I promise you
if their mental health isn't good
they're not gonna be healthy
they're not gonna lose weight
they're not gonna do anything that you want them to do
so I don't know
probably not the best person to talk about this topic because like
I'm still figuring out what that means for myself and like
you know I
I still don't really fully understand how it impacts my life
but like like
it's just it's more than hurt feeling the way people are treated matters
it impacts them
it impacts the way they live their life
it impacts our relationship with the world
a lifetime of persistent and constant cruelty
is going to have an impact on a person
and you cannot claim to care about people
if you are someone that is going to contribute to that